Kevin Harlan joining us Kevin what what
do we call this Tuesday actually down
there on site of this first floor
playing oh this is the start I mean this
is it I mean the winners from this have
been some that has moved to the sweet 16
the Elite Eight we've had one team that
is played in this and gone to the Final
Four so you know with the two games
tonight and two games tomorrow night the
winners advancing to the first rounds on
Thursday and Friday this is very much it
I mean they're they're treating this
like they should it's part of the
tournament well it's not not perhaps the
position they wanted to be in or thought
they'd be in this is the position they
were handed the bit they accepted and
punched and here they are starting
tonight Kevin I have to be selfish here
for a little bit because one of the
great things that I love listening to
you in a broadcast whether it's on
television on radio is always the
uniform description and so I know
tonight
Fairleigh Dickinson and preview a.m. do
you already have the descriptions down
so that you I can get used to getting
ready to listen to them tonight what are
the descriptions of the player uniforms
tonight well we're on TV
so you know I use I just say that for
radio and people even all over the
country and can't see the picture they
don't know what kind of uniforms the
team's are wearing which is all part of
what I think makes radio special as you
you try to just describe what you see
but when you got TV like tonight all it
is is is just kind of accenting the
great pictures that our CBS and Turner
crew will will shoot out to the rest of
the country and the rest of the world
and and it should be pretty I think it
should be a pretty good scene these are
teams that have worked hard to get to
where they are smaller schools
conferences that don't perhaps have a
lot of the major conference Glitter
temples certainly from from their
conference a team that we know and has
been to multiple NCAA tournaments but
but the fact of the matter is the
Fairleigh Dickinson's and
and the Belmonts and some of these other
schools that have been here in the past
are here tonight get a chance to really
shine alone there are no other games
going on unlike Thursday and Friday when
you've got multiple games on multiple
networks being shown many overlapping
but tonight it's just these four teams
these two games with a chance to advance
and become one of the early stories of
this tournament you know Kevin with so
much work that you do whether it's the
NFL MBA and now with college basketball
at what point do you kind of you start
to kind of hone in on your March Madness
preparation is it a full-year length of
just kind of keeping an eye on it or
when does it the Kevin Harlan kind of
bring himself to just go fall basketball
college basketball for the tournament
well my regular season ends with CBS at
the NFL we start college basketball
right after the week after so it begins
just kind of very casually in November
in December and then when they start a
son in games there was at CBS and
January February and and into March
you obviously are knee-deep in it I'm
doing the NBA at the same time for TNT
so there's a lot of basketball to keep
track of but we really don't know where
we're going until Sunday night we don't
know the teams we're going to cover we
don't know where we're going to be
Sunday night so really this is kind of
its kind of like hand-to-hand combat
with the schedule we've got the two
games tonight
we'll jump on a plane after the game and
our site is Des Moines and we'll fly
tonight to get to Iowa and be at
practice at eleven o'clock tomorrow
morning to watch the eight teams
practice and we personally think that
that site is loaded with Michigan and
Michigan State Louisville and Florida I
mean some great great teams are there
with a lot of natural national national
interest in that that
gets us pumped but but you're just
trying to survive with literally every
minute you have this is the only
interview that I'm doing between now and
the weekend because every minute it's so
precious just to get up-to-date make out
your boards get your stories set meet
with your crew meet with the coaches I
mean there's there's just not enough
time so you try to make sure you've got
a good grasp of the headlines
especially with teams like tonight that
I've not seen any of these teams play
except on taped I've done a Michigan
game have done a Michigan State game
this year so I've had a chance to see
them but but a lot of us are going into
this thing blind and you just you're
just it's it's like sure you're fighting
in the jungle you're just you're just
trying to survive and and make sure that
you've got names correct and mascots
correct and records correct and you give
each of these schools that have worked
so hard to get to this platform you work
you work your hardest to make sure that
each of these schools feels you know
important and you've got their
information correct and that you present
their school and their team players and
coach the right way and that really is
at the forefront of our thinking cBS
Turner NCAA tournament play by play and
I mean play by play
I guess caller of everything I call you
an announcer but I can call you an
announcer of NFL as well and an
announcer of the NBA as well but he's on
college right now he's Kevin Harlan and
in Kevin the reason why I want to ask
you this was because you've been
covering you know basketball where this
NBA or college for many years but going
into this tournament
this year's 2019 NCAA tournament I think
the name that everyone pretty much knows
is Zion Williamson like you've seen a
lot of basketball players what have you
seen from Zion Williamson that makes him
so special
well is his footwork is incredible his
basketball acumen his vision on the
floor kind of belies his age he is
sturdy and yet incredibly dynamic and
athletic has a great sense for his team
and he's he's emotionally involved he's
incredibly passionate I always imagined
that if LeBron James played college
basketball
it would have been similar to this you
know the thing about Williamson is he's
been so devastating really from the
get-go but certainly these last three
months or so he's just he's so
captivating in the way he dominates the
game we don't see many players come
along that are like this now we see good
players we'll see you know players that
will go on and become lottery picks and
have a good pro career lead their
college team to to great heights some
great college players fizzle out as NBA
players but this kid has both of those
that things I think covered I think he's
going to be an incredible pro but most
importantly right now with the
tournament and the part that he
considers most important and I applaud
him and his families and the program at
Duke significantly for for you know
coming back from this injured there are
a lot of kids that would have shut it
down there are a lot of families that
would have said are you kidding me we're
going to risk millions hundreds of
millions of dollars to go back and play
and with that injury I mean you know it
luckily was not very serious but it was
enough that a red flag went up in a
flare was shot and people I think had a
moment of pause is you know to what this
kids future was going to be in college
basketball knowing that it was that it
was a one and done and the fact he's
come back was so engaged with his team
while he was injured is so passionate
about the game you know Barkley said it
best Charles said it best he said
basketball players want to play
basketball and sometimes you know it
overrides
what might be a more conservative
cautious view so the thank yous come
back and now it looks like he's playing
it in even higher level and he was
before you know makes him a very unique
story we've not seen a player like this
in many many years so when you're
watching it this weekend and you watch
it next weekend and you probably with
him in Minneapolis the following weekend
I mean I hope we can just all appreciate
with the one Dunn's looking like they're
gonna fizzle out here pretty soon right
that this kid for 18 is as remarkable a
freshman as the game has ever seen
historically as great as the game has
ever seen at this age and of course with
that program just puts him on even
higher a pedestal so I love everything
about the kid I applaud him playing when
he probably could have easily taken off
the shoes figuratively my college career
he has come back and he's playing and I
I this is great for the game sends a
nice message I think too that the team
sometimes is greater than one one person
and I like that story the CBS Turner
NCAA Tournament play-by-play announcer
Kevin Harlan joining the Rich Eisen show
Kirk Morrison filling in for rich and I
know when your preparation Kevin you get
a chance to sit down with these coaches
especially I know in the bracket being
able to sit down with a Tom Izzo and
Michigan State we think of Duke and Mike
sous-chefs key some of these Hall of
Fame head coaches what's always your
biggest takeaway when you sit down with
cultures who have experience in playing
in this type of tournament well Kirk I
think the number one thing is players
come and go right and classes recruiting
classes come and go but really the most
significant emblem of that of that
program is the coach and you talk is oh
and you talk to chefs key and you talk
Bill Self right yeah you talk a friend
don't see a temple who's going to retire
once his team is out of this term in
seven years of age he's been around
forever he's coached Panny coached at
Temple respected head coach you you
think about the players that play but
when you get to these legendary guys
you you you think about how they
represent their program that it's it's
so identified with the coach Calipari at
Kentucky and not on all these guys they
built their reputations
they wear their school colors with great
pride and and and they become as much a
part of why that school is what it is as
the mascot itself so I just I just think
that they've got this in a way of
preparing on short notice for teams
maybe they've not seen early on in
particular in the tournament and and
just have a routine and a system that
they follow they don't try to reinvent
or or deviate or switch up or anything
they they put a system in place and a
preparation for their team in terms of
practice and travel and and time with
with watching film and and and they
don't deviate and and they don't panic
they don't look and go oh woe is me I've
only got a day and a half to prepare I
you know how do we go about this they've
been through it so many times they know
exactly what the drill is and and and
the thing is with all of that I had
about they still love they cannot get
enough of the game they're always
thirsty they're always hungry they
always they want more and that's why
they coach into their 70s when they're
successful because it is such a rush and
they enjoy the process and the kids so
much that when you've got these
legendary coaches it's not just a it's
not the presentation that they make but
it's the presence that they have which
to me is always the most compelling
thing when we sit down and talk with
them the practice day before the games
began or throughout the regular season
when we're broadcasting their games for
CBS Kevin do you ever fill out a bracket
and all these years of them up to my
backside and alligators Kirk I've I've
had four teams I haven't seen tonight
and then I've got eight teams I got to
prepare for for Thursday and Saturday
and then we'll do the regional finals
the weekend after that things will
settle down a little bit or but I get
calls from buddies and even my family
our girl
Collin to CDN I'm filling out my back
edition to put out there you know what
I'm worried about 12 teams right now and
I can't think about what these other
schools are going to do and and and I
and I'm probably better served but but
we at CBS and Turner are required to
have a good feel for the overall
elements that are making this tournament
what they'll be in the 2019 version so
in your mind perhaps you do now listen I
just saw Reggie Miller who I'm working
with tonight Dan Bonner and they filled
out their brackets so so some of us do
and I think the analysts do certainly
that are in our studios and we have a
bunch of them they're all great I just I
guess I just kind of think that I don't
know if I'm smart enough to think that
wide and then focus on what I've got at
the task at hand and I think I'm
probably better by worrying what's right
in front of me as if oh but I am a fan
like everybody else I love this time of
year we're blessed to be doing this as
broadcasters I think we're lucky as fans
to have three weeks tie up so nicely the
national championship and and who the
best teams are and the thrill of that
and we're going to be the first game on
from Des Moines yes I'm Thursday we'll
be on the first game of the tournament
when it gets down to the 64 from Iowa on
Thursday at 12:15 Eastern the next game
will start about a half hour later and
so that responsibility and being in that
position and trying to set the tone for
the next three weeks is really a is
really an honor and and and I don't take
that lightly but I figured that a lot of
times per capita just I better worry
about the teams I've got the broadcast
and and I'll catch up on the other
stories as they as they unfold well I
know tonight 6:40 p.m. Eastern Time on
truTV it's Fairleigh Dickinson Prairie
View A&M the University of Dayton arena
tonight Kevin Harlan will be on a call
along with Reggie Miller you mentioned
Bonner as well look Kevin I will let you
go rests finish up what you got to do I
can't wait for tonight's broadcast meet
to Kirk you're nice to have me on thanks
so much well I look forward to the next
time we did yep you got some NFL NBA
talk next time I'll let you finish up
your college basketball duties
appreciate it
the great Kevin Harlan CBS Turner NCAA
Tournament play-by-play announcer the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience